DETERMINE WHO REALLY COLLUDED
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN AND SCOTT
BOLDMAN.
IT'S GREAT TO SEE ALL I DON'T
HAVE YOU.
YOU'RE AN EXPERT IN INDICTMENTS.
TELL US ABOUT THIS ONE AND YOUR
REACTION TO THE 13 RUSSIANS
NAMED.
>> WELL, IT'S A VERY NARROW
INDICTMENT.
THE MAIN COUNT IS WALL WHAT WE
CALL A CONSPIRACY UNDER THE
GENERAL CONSPIRACY STATUTE AND
BASICALLY SAYS THE RUSSIANS
CONSPIRED TO DEFRAUD FEDERAL
GOVERNMENTAL -- ONE, THEY LIED
ON THEIR VISA APPLICATIONS.
AND THIRD HAS TO DO WITH THE
FOREIGN AGENT REGISTRATION ACT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE REGISTERED AS
FOREIGN AGENTS AND THEY DIDN'T.
AND ONE THING I DON'T THINK
ANYBODY HAS PICKED UP ON,
LEGALLY IT'S NOT THAT
SIGNIFICANT, THE INDICTMENT
DOESN'T EVEN ALLEGE THAT THESE
RUSSIANS WERE PART OF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
IT JUST SAYS THAT THEY WERE
RUSSIAN ORGANIZATIONS.
BUT, LAURA, IT'S VERY NARROW.
IT'S A VERY NARROW CHARGE.
>> AND THIS IS WHAT
CONGRESSENMAN HECK, DANNY HECK
SAID EARLIER TODAY ABOUT WHETHER
DONALD TRUMP IS TRULY VINDICATED
BY THIS NARROW INDICTMENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> DEFENDANTS KNOWINGLY AND
INTENTIONALLY CONSPIRED WITH
EACH OTHER AND WITH PERSONS
KNOWN AND UNKNOWN TO THE GRAND
JURY TO DEFRAUD THE UNITED
STATES, ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
THIS INDICTMENT OF THESE 13
INDIVIDUALS IS NOT THE END OF
IT, JUST LIKE THE INDICTMENTS OF
MR. MANAFORD, MR. GATE,
MR. FLYNN WEREN'T THE END AT
ALL.
TO BE CONTINUED.
>> IS THAT A LITTLE PREMATURE?
>> WELL, LAURA, REMEMBER, THIS
WHOLE THING STARTED WITH
ALLEGATIONS PLAYED UP BY THE
MEDIA AND MY DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUE THAT THERE WAS A
CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY BETWEEN
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN AND THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT TO SUBVERT THE
ELECTION.
THIS INDICTMENT DOESN'T EVEN
COME CLOSE TO DOING THAT.
AND IN FACT, FOR ROD ROSENSTEIN
TO SAY NO AMERICANS WERE
INVOLVED AND IT HAD NO EFFECT ON
THE ELECTION, IT JUST SHOWS YOU
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN PROMISING
AND PROMOTING THIS NARRATIVE FOR
OVER A YEAR NOW, REALLY A YEAR
AND A HALF.
AND AT THIS STAGE, I DON'T SEE
WHY YOU KNEE A SPECIAL COUNCIL
FOR ANY OF THESE INDICTMENTS.
>> BUT IT ALSO SAID KNOWN AND
UNKNOWN.
THEY ALSO SAID PEOPLE KNOWN AND
UNKNOWN DID CONSPIRE WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
COULDN'T THAT THEN -- I HAVEN'T
BEEN A LAWYER FOR A WHILE.
SAUL AND SCOTT CAN CONTRADICT
ME.
BUT DOESN'T THAT LEAVE THE DOOR
OPEN FOR NAMING OF FUTURE
INDIVIDUALS.
>> ON VIRTUALLY ALL INDICTMENTS
HAVE THAT LANGUAGE.
BUT ROD ROSENSTEIN DID NOT SAY
THAT THERE WAS NO COLLUSION WITH
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HE SAID THIS INDICTMENT DOESN'T
ALLEGE THAT THERE WAS COLLUSION.
AND THIS INDICTMENT DOESN'T
ALLEGE THAT THE ELECTION WAS
AFFECTED.
SO YOU CAN'T SAY ANYTHING
BROADER THAN THAT.
>> YEAH, I CERTAINLY HAVE TO
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THE
REPUBLICANS ARE CELEBRATING.
THIS IS ONE BUCKET.
THIS IS ONE INDICTMENT OF
CYBERSPACE.
THERE'S STILL -- THIS
INVESTIGATION CONTINUES.
EVERY CHANCE YOU GET, YOU WANT
TO SAY THAT THERE'S NO COLLUSION
AND IT VINDICATES THE PRESIDENT.
IT CERTAINLY DOESN'T.
IT'S ONE PART OF A PUZZLE.
>> I AGREE.
IT'S A NARROW INDICTMENT.
BUT I THINK IT IS VERY KEY THAT
THE RUSSIAN INVOLVEMENT IN THIS
ELECTION WAS BOTH PRO-TRUMP,
ANTI-TRUMP, HELPING JILL STEIN
AT ONE POINT.
THEY SEEM TO HAVE THEIR HAND ALL
OVER EVERYTHING.
>> I WOULD, TOO.
IF I WERE THE RUSSIANS AND
SOWING DISCORD, I WOULD
CERTAINLY DO BOTH.
THEY WERE PROMOTING VOTER
SUPPRESSION AS WELL IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITIES.
>> TO HAVE PRO AND ANTI-TRUMP
RALLIES ON THE SAME DAYS.
THAT SEEMS LIKE A STRETCH.
SAUL IS RIGHT.
THIS IS ONE INDICTMENT.
THE IDEA THAT MUELLER IS GOING
TO CLOSE UP SHOP TOMORROW.
HE JUST GOT $10 MILLION IN THAT
RIDICULOUS REPUBLIC BUDGET THAT
WAS SIGNED.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE NEEDS $10
MILLION IF HE'S GOING TO WRAP IT
UP.
GO AHEAD.
>> SO WE HAVE ALL THIS TIME
THAT'S HAPPENED.
CONGRESSIONAL COMMITTEES,
SPECIAL COUNCIL.
AND WHAT EVIDENCE IS THERE OF
COLLUSION OTHER THAN THE STEELE
DOSSIER, WHICH HAS BEEN
DISCREDITED.
AND SO I THINK IT'S ONE THING TO
SAY THAT THERE WERE RUSSIAN
NATIONALS OR EVEN RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT INVOLVED.
ALTHOUGH I WOULD NOTE, NONE OF
THE HACKING, WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
THE MOST SERIOUS, NONE OF THAT
WAS ALLEGED IN THE INDICTMENT
AND NOT SOMETHING THAT WAS DEALT
WITH.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE AND I JUST
THINK SO MUCH OF THIS HAS BEEN
BASED OFF WISHFUL THINKING BY
THE PRESS AND THE DEMOCRATS AND
THE STEELE DOSSIER RATHER THAN
HARD FACTS.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE REPUBLICANS
WHO ARE LEADING ALL OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS AND CERTAINLY
BELIEVE THAT THERE WAS RUSSIAN
MEDDLING?
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
I'M A FORMER PROSECUTOR.
PROSECUTIONS DON'T START AT THE
TOP AND GO DOWN.
THEY START AT THE BOTTOM.
IT'S CALLED A PYRAMID
PROSECUTION.
YOU GET TO THE TOP AND CUT THE
TOP OFF.
YOU CUT THE HEAD OFF.
THIS IS ONE BUCKET.
THERE'S JUST ONE BUCKET OF
CYBERBULLYING.
THERE WAS OTHER COLLUSION AND
OTHER FACTS STILL BEING
INVESTIGATED.
>> RUSSIAN MEDDLING IS
DIFFERENT THAN A CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY BETWEEN TRUMP AND THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S A HUGE LEAP AND THERE'S
NOT BEEN EVIDENCE TO MAKE THAT
LEAP.
>> NOT RIGHT NOW.
>> THEY HAVEN'T OFFERED I THINK
ANYTHING ON THAT FRONT.
AND ROSENSTEIN ESSENTIALLY SAID
THAT TODAY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT IN THIS INDICTMENT.
BUT, SAUL, I WANT TO GO INTO
THIS MORE WITH YOU BECAUSE WHEN
YOU SEE THE AMOUNT OF TIME THEY
HAVE HAD, THEY'VE INTERVIEWED A
LOT OF PEOPLE, THEY'VE REVIEWED
A LOT OF DOCUMENTS, IT IS QUITE
SOMETHING, I THINK, AT THIS
JUNCTURE IN THE INVESTIGATION TO
COME UP WITH, OKAY, THEY WERE
TRYING TO MANIPULATE THE
ELECTION.
WHO DIDN'T THINK THAT?
BUT BEFORE TRUMP WAS EVEN
ANNOUNCED AS A CANDIDATE, THEY
WERE MEDDLING.
AND WHAT DID THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DO TO STOP IT?
LAST TIME I CHECKED, THEY WERE
APPROVING SALES OF ALMOST 20% OF
OUR URANIUM SUPPLY.
YOU START TALKING ABOUT THE WAYS
WE HELPED RUSSIA.
WE HELPED RUSSIA A LOT DURING
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
IT'S MORE OF A POLITICAL AND
HISTORICAL POINT.
THE INDICTMENT SAYS IN STARTED
IN 2014, WELL BEFORE TRUMP
ANNOUNCED.
BUT, LISTEN, THERE'S NO
QUESTION.
WHAT SCOTT SAYS IS RIGHT.
IT'S A PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
BUT WHAT THE CONGRESSMAN SAID IS
CORRECT, TOO.
IT IS A GOOD DAY FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
IT IS SIGNIFICANT THAT THE
INVESTIGATION HAS GONE ON THIS
LONG AND YOU DON'T HAVE THE
COLLUSION CASE.
AND KEEP IN MIND, AS ANDREW
MCCARTHY HAS POINTED OUT, IF YOU
LOOK AT THE FLYNN PLEA PAPERS,
IT LOOKS LIKE THERE IS GOING TO
BE NO COLLUSION CASE, CERTAINLY
NO COLLUSION THAT FLYNN WOULD
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT.
SO ALL SIGNS DO POINT TO THE
FACT THAT THERE WILL NOT BE A
MAJOR -- AND WHEN I SAY
COLLUSION --
>>THERE'S GOING TO BE WHAT?
WHAT ARE THEY LOOKING FOR?
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE,
INTERFERING WITH THE
INVESTIGATION.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YOU WOULDN'T HAVE TRUMP --
>>THERE'S NO OBSTRUCTION CASE.
>> THE INVESTIGATION'S NOT OVER
YET.
>> HOLD ON.
GO AHEAD.
>> IT'S PURE CONJECTURE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING.
>> THERE IS NO OBSTRUCTION
CASE, PERIOD.
>> WE'VE GOT THE PRESIDENT'S
OWN WORDS.
I'M NOT GOING TO GO DOWN THAT
RABBIT HOLE WITH YOU.
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
EVIDENCE THERE.
>> IT'S NOT A RABBIT HOLE.
IT'S THE LAW.
>> THERE'S LAWS IN THE RABBIT
HOLE.
>> RIGHT NOW THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
TURNED UP THE HEAT ON THE
REPUBLICAN COMMITTEES LOOKING
INTO THIS BECAUSE THEY'RE
ARGUING THAT, OH, YOU GUYS ARE
JUST INTERFERING WITH WHAT THE
SPECIAL COUNCIL IS TRYING TO GET
AT.
INDICTMENTS COME OUT TODAY.
WHAT'S NEXT FOR THE HOUSE
INVESTIGATION?
>> IT'S GOING TO CONTINUE.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT IS NEXT
KIND OF UNDER THE MICROSCOPE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO SCRUTINIZE
PEOPLE LIKE JOHN BRENNAN AND SEE
THEIR ROLE IN THIS.
SIX MONTHS AGO, PEOPLE DIDN'T
KNOW THE DEMOCRATS PAID FOR THE
DOSSIER.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF SENIOR PEOPLE
IN THE DOJ OR FBI EITHER GET
DEMOTED OR LEAVE THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT IF
THEY HAD DONE EVERYTHING BY THE
BOOK.
>> BRENNAN SENT OUT A TWEET
TODAY.
HE SAID DOJ STATEMENT AND
INDICTMENTS
INDICTMENT
INDICTMENTS, CLAIMS OF A HOAX.
MY TAKE, IMPLAUSIBLE THAT
RUSSIAN ACTIONS DID NOT
INFLUENCE THE VIEWS AND VOTES OF
AT LEAST SOME AMERICANS.
OKAY, I GUESS.
BUT HOW DOES THAT JUSTIFY A
SPECIAL COUNCIL BEING CALLED ON
THIS PRESIDENT?
BUT WHEN ROSENSTEIN PICKED THE
SPECIAL COUNCIL, SAID WE'VE GOT
TO DO THE SPECIAL COUNCIL, THAT
WAS BASED ON WHAT?
I GO BACK TO ROD'S DECISION TO
CALL THE SPECIAL COUNCIL, WHICH
I THINK WAS ABSURD ON ITS FACE.
YOU CAN CLOSE IT OUT.
>> I DISAGREE.
I THINK IT ABSOLUTELY IS CALLED
FOR BY THE REGULATION, JUST LIKE
PRESIDENT OBAMA SHOULD HAVE
APPOINTED A SPECIAL COUNCIL.
THE POINT IS YOU CAN'T HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT HAS BEEN
ACCUSED OF THROWING AN ELECTION
INVESTIGATING ITSELF.
IF YOU LOOK AT --
>>WHAT WAS THE PROBABLE CAUSE
OR ANY INDICATION THAT A CRIME
HAD BEEN COMMITTED?
>> YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
PROBABLE CAUSE UNDER THE
REGULATION.
AND, LOOK, I THINK THAT LORETTA
LYNCH SHOULD HAVE APPOINTED A
SPECIAL COUNCIL BECAUSE OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL THING.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO, BUT THE POINT
IS THE LANGUAGE OF THE SPECIAL
COUNCIL REGULATION ALLOWS YOU TO
DO IT.
>> YOU CAN DO A LOT.
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU SHOULD.
RON, YOUR TAKE AND THEN SCOTT
AND THEN WE'VE GOT TO GO.
>> ROD ROSENSTEIN IN THE
APPOINTING ORDER DID NOT
IDENTIFY THE CRIME TO BE
INVESTIGATED.
HE SAID, INVESTIGATE COMEY'S
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION.
THE REGULATIONS ONLY ALLOW FOR A
SPECIAL COUNCIL FOR A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
HE DID NOT DO THAT, AND THAT'S
WHY A LOT OF US HAVE BEEN
CONCERNED THIS INVESTIGATION
DIDN'T HAVE ANY REAL LIMITS.
>> THAT'S NOT ACCURATE.
>> OKAY.
SCOTT.
>> INVESTIGATING RUSSIAN
MEDDLING IN THE ELECTION.